hi in this video we are going to talk
about the allosteric regulation of
enzymes we know that in case of enzymes
may have an active site which binds to
the substrate now other than the active
site many enzymes has allosteric site
now this allosteric site could be a
binding site for several modulators
which we are turning as allosteric
modulator x' now the allosteric site
might be also same as the active site in
case of many enzymes so let's look at it
so here is an enzyme where a particular
allosteric modulator has born now this
binding of allosteric modulator might
change its active site conformation so
look at the active site after binding to
the allosteric modulator the active site
conformation is now changed as a result
this enzyme is no more able to bind to
the substrate and the substrate cannot
bind nicely to the enzymes active site
in this case a negative regulation is
taking place and it is affecting the
enzymes velocity and the affinity
towards the substrate right so this is
one kind of anesthetic modulation so in
this case we have learned that the
historic modulator change the
conformation of the active site in such
a way that the substrate is not able to
bind to the active site with the same
amount of affinity the affinity of the
binding is reduced after the historic
modulation so illustrate modulation
could be both positive and negative in
nature that may augment the reaction
velocity or it might reduce it depending
upon the case it might be turned as
allosteric activator or a mistake
inhibitor so let's try to look at the
kinetic data of allosteric enzymes and
we try to compare it with the Michaelis
Menten enzymes Michaelis Menten enzymes
shows a hyperbolic curve in comparison
to Michaelis Menten enzymes when we see
the kinetics of allosteric enzyme
it does not follow Michaelis Menten
statistics rather than it shows a
sigmoidal curve and this Sigma yield
curve is a hallmark for cooperativity in
a moment we would understand what is
cooperativity so allosteric enzymes
curve is very different from Michaelis
Menten enzyme curve now illustrative
modulators can change the affinity
towards a substrate and it can also
change the reaction velocity so let's
look at the first case in this case the
red curve is the curve without any arrow
streak activator now with the binding of
allosteric activator or allosteric
inhibitor inhibitor the curve change
differently so you can see here all the
cases the maximum velocity is not that
much changed but the affinity has been
changed right in the next case we can
see the historic modulator can change
the reaction velocity as well in this
case you can see the reaction velocity
has been dramatically decreased in case
of allosteric inhibitor an increase in
case of allosteric activator
so in short allosteric modulator z' can
both work in a positive and negative
fashion to modulate the affinity and the
reaction velocity now here is an enzyme
which is not regulated which is
regulated by allosteric modulator
but it's illustrate modulator is itself
the substrate so this kind of regulation
is known as homo tropic allosteric
modulation in other case when the
substrate and the other steric modulator
are two different entities this case is
known as hydrophobic allosteric
modulator
now let's take the example of both the
cases so let's take an example of
glycolysis pathway since we know it very
nicely so three enzymes of glycolysis
pathway are under allosteric regulations
which are hexokinase phosphofructokinase
and pyruvate kinase
so let's look at XO kinase so extra
various converts glucose to
glucose-6-phosphate in this situation
you have too much of you go 6-phosphate
it can work as a negative regulator of
hexokinase and it can give a feedback
inhibition to hexagon gays it makes a
lot of sense because when you have too
much of X so as you go 6-phosphate then
you don't need to run the pathway
multiple times because already your
pathway would be diverting to the
glycolytic flux and you could generate a
lot of ATP in this situation you don't
need to generate further ATP right in
that case glucose 6-phosphate works as a
feedback inhibitor for an extra pangas
enzyme let's take a look at hydrophobic
modulators for example a MP and ATP
works differently in this pathway when
you have too much ATP you don't need to
run the glycolytic pathway to get ATP in
that situation
ATP inhibits pyruvate kinase and
phosphofructokinase whereas a MP is a
signature that we don't have that much
of ATP in our body our body is running
through low level of ATP in that
situation we need to run the glycolytic
pathway as a result ALP works as a
positive modulator of hospital - kinase
and pyruvate kinase so we looked at that
in any kind of biochemical pathway there
could be no trophy and heterotrophic
allosteric modulation and all of these
modulations
are done in order to meet the
physiological requirement
so the illustrate enzymes are mostly
complex enzymes having more than one
subunits and each of these enzymes might
have our active and inactive
conformation which this switch in
between now binding of allosteric
modulator x' in this case look at this
illustrating modulator might change the
confirmation of the nearby active site
making it more accessible towards a
substrate such that the substrate can
bind not only that it can change the
confirmation of the dis
active site and ensuring more substrate
can bind to the nearby active site so
binding of the substrate is actually
happening in a cooperative fashion and
that brings out the point of
cooperativity now in that case we can
take the example of hemoglobin and
oxygen binding to it now exactly if
you're given is not an enzyme but still
the modulation type is a strict
regulation and cooperative back binding
so here is the hemoglobin in an inactive
state when it's not bound to order now
one oxygen molecule binding to one
subunit of the chemo globin make other
subunit more accessible towards oxygen
binding such that it is easier for other
subunit to bind to the oxygen and in
this subsequent fashion all the subunits
bind to oxygen and it creates the
oxygenated hemoglobin which is very
important for our physiological
accidents other than smoking we can take
an example from our own nervous system
in our system we have a molecule known
as commercially dependent kinase to camp
k2 which when don't bind to calcium it
is in its closed conformation and in
this conformation is in active state but
when it binds to calcium it alters its
conformation and becomes more open and
this is very important for synaptic
plasticity long-term potentiation and
many other aspects of synaptic
physiology so we can understand that how
spike in calcium level can lead to
contradiction in the conformation change
of CAM k2 and as a result the
physiological properties would be
altered so in this video of the overall
looked at the principle of allosteric
modulation we looked at the kinetic data
how it affects the reaction velocity or
the affinity of the enzyme towards a
substrate and we also took an
example of hemoglobin and camp k2 to
understand the allosteric modulation so
I hope you enjoyed this introductory
video about allosterism in subsequent
video be able to talk about the kinetics
in much more details so stay tuned and
make sure you comment at the end of this
video such that it gives me some
positive motivation motivation to make
more videos thank you